I really felt like for once I connected
with the Germans your bread actually got
it which uh pains me to say I think
British Cuisine is better oh I know I
hello welcome to another episode of the
trash taste podcast I'm your host Joey
and I'm with the boys as per usual but
we're in a different location where are
we we're back in England baby let's go
we're back in the UK uh very gracious of
the side mental letters take over their
set today yeah thank you we've got this
nice little side men
look at that look at that branded
cushions every time I go to a different
YouTuber Studio I'm like God damn
everyone has so much space yeah it's
like our studio [__]
but we just finished our European tour
yeah yeah God damn yesterday yesterday
so literally the grind doesn't stop we
finished uh nine shows and then we're
like let's record a bunch of podcast
episodes because we have not had enough
of talking yeah yeah was it nine shows
or ten shows like it was nine shows oh
[__] yeah nine shows we're done
um but like unlike the American tour it
was way would you say it was more
intense or less intense it was more and
less intense at the same time and
unfortunately we'd have a beer on us so
we can only like cheers with our drinks
but cheers cheers
cheers to another
um tour over guys yeah uh but yeah in
the America Tour we had I think 24 shows
in six weeks yeah uh six or seven weeks
and uh in this tour we had nine shows in
about a week and a half yeah so
technically it was more intense but I
think just because it was like a way
shorter time it felt less intense
overall yeah I think because like near
the second half of the tour we got a lot
of questions being like oh you know we
saw the schedule like you guys did like
six shows in a row in six days in five
different countries does that not just
like [__] you up and like but I don't
know because we did we did three shows
in a row for the American tour yeah like
right now and I felt dead yeah that that
[__] us up so yeah so I was dreading
the six days in a row and I was just
like oh God I'm gonna be dead by the end
of it but weirdly enough it wasn't that
bad no I I don't know why I mean I think
the reason why is because America all
looks the same and that's something he
was [__] my head up when I would I
would travel 15 hours and it looked
exactly it looks exactly the same uh
like a lot of the like Middle America
looks so similar that is true so I think
just waking up in a new kind of setting
every time it's like wow cool yeah and a
lot of the countries were all about
first time right so yeah it was a little
bit more exciting I feel yeah and like I
think like comparing to some of the
American cities that we went to we went
to some amazing American cities and then
we also went to [__] Ohio as well uh
and there is there's no hires on this
yeah there is there is a big difference
between waking up and being like Oh I'm
in Amsterdam today oh wait Copenhagen
Stockholm and then waking up and uh
seeing a cod zombie map and I'm like oh
we are performing here yeah okay I'm
celebrating my birthday here yeah yeah
so uh the vibe which is very different
just because every city every country
was just a different culture we try
provide different foods every day
um so that's enough about being nice
we've got to tear list the countries now
the countries
all right so okay so what we found out
gladly let's just get this out oh uh
France is the Ohio of Europe that is
something that we have found out I'm so
glad because I thought it was going to
be the UK funnily enough not many
countries clowned on the UK yeah for
context in the show we we ask ask the
audience to name a country in Europe uh
they would not like to be isakai too
yeah yeah France was generally number
one yeah only a few exceptions like when
Sweden and Denmark wanted to beef it out
yeah but everyone pretty much said
France all the time which I was proud of
honestly because like as someone who's
not from Europe I didn't know that as
just a thing yeah well what do
Australians like French people
um we're like do you have any opinions
on them yeah really oh really is so far
away where it's like I mean you're never
gonna interact with like French people
from France in Australia but maybe every
now and then so it's like I don't know
we're too busy beefing with New Zealand
yeah I was gonna ask if we do a show in
Australia do you guys think you'd put
New Zealand on 100 I would be I would be
shocked if New Zealand is not at least
in the top [__] Tasmania or something
[__]
hey I don't know I've never been to
Tasmania might be nice who knows I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna jump to conclusions
yeah all right tier list food rating
European food rating food rating all
right [__] Denmark hot dogs
I went to like spent six weeks in
America I think I had one hot dog and I
was satisfied I had two days in Denmark
I had four hot dogs and that was not
enough for me I had four hot dogs I only
had two wow wow I love sausages yeah
there was definitely a sleeper hit I
mean I I'd never heard of people saying
that hot dogs in Denmark again but then
apparently all Danish people are like
yeah hot dogs are good yeah but why
aren't they like flaunting anymore well
because I think it's it's someone's
saying it's owned by the government or
something like yes it's government
subsidized right or like all like
control like the quality is controlled
by the government or something because
you're so big brain because the same
Sweden as well yeah so because all the
hot dogs are just great yeah it's so
[__] good and they had like the like
you had like different toppings on it as
well so you could basically build your
own hot dogs with some of these stands
and so many of these stands so there
wasn't really like a hot dog kind of
like brands that you buy there or most
of them are like I think it was a brand
uh was it well there were Brands but a
lot of them there were just a lot of
independent Sellers as well and like
some of the hot dog stands are just like
homemade sauces and all of them were
just Godlike dude I knew it was going to
be goaded because the first hot dog we
had was the Ho the the airport hot dog
yeah and like normally airport food
you're kind of just like you know give
or take but yeah we had it was just like
oh is a big brain idea I've never seen
an airport do this in Denmark as you're
waiting for your bags there's just tons
of food and drink places yeah literally
like two like 10 meters why do not why
do airports not do that because they
want to make you feel like [__] yeah
clearly I don't know maybe there's some
some weird rules around selling it at
the baggage I don't [__] know what no
one does this no I've never seen it but
like it was because I wasn't gonna have
a hot dog because I wasn't even hungry
uh and then we were just waiting for
baggage and I think our bags were late
and then I think it was one of you two
that was just like I'm gonna get a hot
dog yeah I'm like all right you know you
you know I've been to America I've had
hot dogs before I don't I don't want a
hot dog in Denmark ew and then I saw the
hot dog and it was the fattest looking
hot dog I've ever seen with all these
different kind of kinds of toppings
trash taste conversations like two
minutes gushing over a hot dog it is
really good I mean Copenhagen is
renowned for having some of the most
best food in the world but my God that
glizzy's got to be up there yeah do you
know do you know what sold me do you
know do you know do you know the biggest
thing that sold me the hot dog was like
twice the size of the bun you know
sometimes you have a hot dog and it's
just a [__] tiny ass hot dog bun yeah
I kind of like it when the hot dog [__]
off
if I had to choose I would definitely
choose a little more sausage yeah yeah
you've got to have a few bites with just
the dog and then the dog a little bit of
like tip
but I don't want like hold on
inches
there's no way you can Source it and
it'll be stabilized on the hot dog no
because I want to taste like a little
bit of like what the hot dog tastes by
itself you know I want to have the taste
of the meat and then you have like the
combination afterwards and then you end
up with a little bit of bread actually
well I've been on a [__] bread uh
Odyssey on this Europe trip so in every
single show I got ask the question So
Gone has your opinion on bread changed
and uh I can confirm that uh bread does
taste different guys what can I say
Revelation what what bugged me guys that
you were coping and you were like we
shouldn't have good bread in the UK
I stick by that we do I stick by that
you just never looked for it gone well
like listen it's okay it's okay if it's
not easily accessible
I go to the [__] Tesco's I go to the
Sainsbury's
in front of me it doesn't exist [__]
7-Eleven in America and be like why is
there no fresh food what you got you go
into [__] Europe and you trip over
like a bakery every time you go into a
restaurant and they give you like a
basket of bread every [__] time would
you get that in [__] spoons no you
don't did you get a girl
that's the point right it's just not as
like easily it's it's not as like common
but we have it it's it's there gone I'm
sure we have it but like that's like
saying okay yeah I want to find a good
Italian restaurant you have to search up
Italian food you know that's that
doesn't mean it's like
sorry can you believe I have to look up
a restaurant no if you want like good
food that is not from like your Cuisine
then you have to like look up a
restaurant that not only does the
cuisine but does it well right in in the
UK it's just like it's just harder to
find access to good bread and the most
mass-produced bread it's just the same
old [__] white bread okay okay okay
that's absolutely not absolutely not we
actually have a deal yeah
that's so handy oh wow we have them
already okay this is actually super
healthy I guess yeah so uh let's let's
start from the top actually so we the
first stop was Ireland
okay we have Island now yeah uh Island
was solid I think which is like the
nicest thing I could say without talking
yeah you know I I really really [__]
love Ireland uh I do think Dublin is the
I wouldn't even say like the worst place
just like the weakest place that island
has because you got outside of Dublin
and everything's [__] beautiful and
you go to Dublin and it's just like oh
what's there to do there uh there's the
Guinness Factory and uh there's a
whiskey taste I will say uh I've never
seen a higher concentration of white
Americans than Dublin I think I saw more
Americans in Dublin than I think Irish
people than Dublin yeah so I I'd never
yeah I can't even imagine maybe like the
Daytona 500 is where you would see that
many other white people but it was
insane I it was the entire Guinness tour
was just Americans really yeah uh and
actually too Fair one thing that we
learned while we were in Dublin is that
apparently they're like they're obsessed
with Chinese food like Ireland has an
obsession with like their version of
Chinese food yeah uh because John took
us to some Chinese food and it was it
was good but I don't think it stood out
compared to the other countries you went
to the dog I ain't going all the way to
double any Chinese food that's not how
that works I think Ireland could go in
uh oh god oh your spice bags
yeah I didn't know that was a I don't
know if it's a Dublin special or Ireland
special if Ireland's food was like not
compared to the other countries that
we're talking with him it would be a
solid it would hire but I think because
we have these other countries we need to
thin out this tier list yeah I want to
say seat here seat here are we talking
about just the food or just the just
food only just the herbs don't count why
don't work out no because then that's a
realist in countries and it feels that
feels weird
racism
I I think that we do the food and I
think Ireland is a solid sea I think our
people agree because skin if unless
we're counting Guinness is food then
yeah I mean it's liquidation
I mean I will say B just for the
Guinness alone too much [__] Guinness
I'm gonna rate the Guinness and I'm
gonna put it in a beer yeah
100 that's a meal okay
second our second show was in Copenhagen
in Denmark I mean are we basing that
just off the hot dog yes
triple had um
Thai food
which actually was some of the best Thai
food I've had not in Thailand that was
insane it's very wholesome I was like
can you can you can you talk tie to them
yeah I think I think that the woman over
there is time yeah no because you don't
understand right when you go to a
restaurant that there's Thai outside of
Thailand and the staff of Thai if they
know that one of you speaks Thai it's
just a different restaurant oh yeah it's
just a different it's a different meal
and so I think this is I think anyone
from like southeast Asia or maybe he's
like even like the southern South
American countries can like relate to
this but so you know the person running
the restaurant was uh kind of like a
Thai Auntie kind of thing you know
um you know she was you know obviously
an older Thai woman and uh we come in we
start off speaking English you know she
gives us the normal treatment uh and
then as soon as I start speaking Thai
she goes on full Auntie mode all right
she she and uh because I was I I asked
her inside yo I'm looking to you know
show my friends some good Thai food uh
do you like I was thinking of ordering
this this this and she goes okay one
thing about Asian uh especially South
East Asian like aunties we anyone who's
been to a family gathering knows the men
don't run ship it's it is the aunties
that call the shots okay you may think
the men run things in Southeast Asia no
once the aunties want to do something
they are getting it done yeah they are
they are the secret mafia boss so I was
like I'm thinking you're ordering this
this and she goes no no no no I'll order
for you you need this this this this and
this it was all really good yeah yeah
and it was it was insane yeah yeah yeah
yeah we also had went to some other kind
of I think winter is like a Danish
restaurant where it was like lamb yeah
yeah that's right some other stuff it
was pretty good I honestly you guys said
asked here I think hot dogs are carrying
it but I think it's a I think it's a too
nah the hot dogs are asked here 100
agree if we have a separate calorie no
man that lamb was pretty dope it was
good and I feel like we had better meals
all right well actually we didn't all
share the same meals though as well that
is true yeah no I I still think I'm
still sticking it I I'm sticking with
Esther uh you may say the hot dogs are
carrying but I'm happy for hot dogs to
Solo Carry those hot dogs are
life-changing I cannot have an American
hot dog ever again because I'm just
gonna be thinking how how much better
the Danish hot dogs are listen I I think
the Costco hot dog has a soft spot in my
heart get the [__] out it's 1.50 for the
combo why are you saying the Costco hot
dogs are better no no no the Danish
lizards I did not say that I said it had
a soft spot in my heart because they're
cheap I can't I can't go back man okay
my question then okay did you have a
better meal than in Denmark was there a
meal that you had like don't tell me
where but do you think you had a meal
that was better than Denmark too many s
tears a meal that was better than
Denmark in your head for you Joe uh uh
no okay gone uh I have one that was
equal okay okay I know which one it is
okay yeah yeah
after Denmark you went to Amsterdam
right yeah yeah look at that beautiful
Glizzy look at that yeah look how long
then uh one dollar that's too much too
much
it looks like it's a one dollar fifty
hot dog man come on where are the
toppings man that looks naked compared
to some of the things there is a topping
station God did you know that if the hot
dog uh Costco was had gone with
inflation as in like when it was
originally priced at 1.50 it should be
like four dollars fifty something yeah
didn't didn't the Costco hot dog go up
in price at one point no no the CEO or
the CEO or one of them was in a meeting
and was like I will kill you if you
raise the price of the hot dog
it was it was experience great he was
like you will not rate because they lose
money on the hot dogs yeah yeah which is
which I I just love that that they're
like
foreign
[Music]
dogs is that there's not just one you
have like so many different varieties as
well you have some of the spicy hot dogs
the bacon wrapped hot dogs you know the
the usual hot dogs as well the thin hot
dogs there are there's just so much
choice I don't know how this is even an
argument look at this issue that's a
four that's such value that you get with
the Costco hot dog how can you bet again
four dollars it should cost it hasn't
changed since the 80s
isn't that crazy
years of value God that's just beaten
inflation yeah I just absolute you know
I mean I think that them keeping that
price at 1.50 has done more good PR for
Costco than anything else oh 100 okay
okay so after that we went to Amsterdam
or Rotterdam and then Amsterdam yeah so
yeah this is a little bit biased because
this is the only country where we did
two shows in I don't remember the meals
I had yeah yeah actually no we uh you
know despite the French best croissant
of my life I had it really yeah yeah
actually I agree it was serious [__]
because we were sitting down on the cafe
and we could smell the grass on so we
were like oh could we get one of those
she's like oh it takes 30 minutes but
it's baked to order yeah and I was like
okay Jesus Christ I had uh the best I
can't remember what it's called what's
the one where it's like a poached egg
and Hollandaise sauce
eggs benedict of my life really
Amsterdam yeah
there's one core memory I have for it
though I'm calling you out Nabi Nabi we
were in the we were in this Cafe right
yeah and it was kind of it was kind of
slow uh and um but this is like one
thing you can never do in European
restaurants
which you do do in Japanese restaurants
right so we're sitting down and you know
we I was on a bit of a time crunch uh
and uh we were just kind of trying to
get their attention and then that'd be
good for across the Russia goes excuse
me
yeah yeah and you can see me and Connor
just recorded every coil into our seats
like this and like no it would only make
it worse by the fact that she goes yes
I'm coming
I was like no no no yeah
at most you can do the half-hand race
the way we do it in Europe is you
awkwardly wait for like eye contact and
you're just like ah excuse me it's a
very inefficient just yeah we could do
with the Sumo sound but I think people
would abuse it yeah that's true but I
think the croissants would helped and I
okay I've been to France a lot that was
the best craft song I've ever had in my
life okay you're not gonna lie I don't
remember a single meal are you rating at
C tier then or BTS Like I can't even
rate it I don't remember anything I ate
I had a had something called um wild
beer what wild beer I went to this uh
Cafe I thought it was for food but I
guess it was beer and I kind of felt
pressured into getting a beer because
the guy was like we don't have anything
but beer I was like okay uh it was a
cafe uh so I was like okay because you
have coffee he's like no just beer
um and he he was like do you want
something basic he said the word basic
okay or do you want something
interesting so yeah it's I guess it's
kind of like this yeah it's pulling it
up now it's like this it wasn't like a
brand it was like a style of beer and I
knew it was kind of weird when he
brought out a glass bottle and had a
cork in it what and he Uncorked the beer
and it tastes like wine and it was like
nine percent uh it was extremely sour
um
he was trying to explain to me what it
was I I couldn't I couldn't for the life
of you tell me it sounded like it was
like yeah we just throw it in the casket
and then we opened it up
that's wild looking yeah I don't know
yeah maybe maybe I don't know what on
Earth it was
yeah it just keeps coming up the same
thing yeah I have no idea how to it was
it was yeah he said it was like they
have it in like a keg and they bottle it
and put it in a cork it was so
interesting I do though remember
actually it's not a meal but I do
remember a cool memory uh because we
went to McDonald's
I'm not saying anything it's up to you
guys but like the one cool memory I had
was like it was it was me and a bunch of
the crew and we were like you know what
let's just go get something really quick
because you know we're not even that
hungry just a quick bite to eat we we
saw a McDonald's I was five minutes down
the road and obviously you know because
it's Amsterdam right like every street
has bike lanes and everyone's biking
everywhere and I don't know what these
like kids problems were but there were
two kids on bikes that were just like
constantly circling the block that we
were on and then out of nowhere they
just threw like a Twix bar at us
like straight up like this kid on a bike
had like I don't know if you had like a
box of Twix or something like in his
backpack but he just like pulled one out
and just pegged it at us he hit Sarah on
the head on the head and then Mike and
Guy our staff were just like I'm gonna
[__] kill those kids and uh yeah
that's the only thing I remember about
Amsterdam oh that's that's that's funny
because uh when we were in Copenhagen
it's funny that you know generally
Danish people seem pretty chill they
were like very very polite and chill one
of like the politest shows we've had uh
which doesn't say much about Europe
because everyone there is polite
um and everyone's chill except when you
[__] up on the bike lane I I it's if you
don't know the exact bike etiquette I've
never had so much abuse thrown at me
just my passing cyclist to be like they
do it in such a calm demeanor as well
you know it's never like a shout or like
a like like a big exaggeration it's just
you know if like I had that once where
like I almost [__] ran into another
cyclist because I didn't realize that oh
there's red lights for bikes yeah in
Denmark and I didn't see that I ran
through almost hit a guy and as I was
passing through him in the Karma's voice
he was just like what the [__]
so I just like slowly slowed down right
and I thought that was like the escort
just like don't stop a minute you just
like slow down and come to a stop and
then as I do I I haven't I ordered a
Dutch woman just like psycho boss me and
just go [__]
I don't like whoa what
yeah it's so fun it's because they're so
chill it feels so bad yeah it's it's the
way it's the chill way they say it you
know if if they shout out to me I'll
just be like it's the passive
aggressiveness yeah yeah yeah for sure
all right well I have no room to rate uh
Netherlands food because I had
McDonald's purely not remembering
anything other than a croissant I'm just
gonna put it in C just because something
needs to go and see all right
um do you agree with that guy
we have to thin this out because we
can't just put everything in snakes as a
cop-out uh Wales is well well well this
is what else is his moments all right
I'm biased yeah you know as much as we
uh you guys big up the leak soup right
yeah battle breathe goes hard but you
don't have to eat that that's fine
um okay so after that was Sweden Sweden
was by far yeah
we we okay here's what I did uh we got
there and I messaged Felix I was like
where do I go because if this is not
from Stockholm but he's from yeah he was
like I was like is there one spot I
gotta go eat and so he sent me this
restaurant he was like yeah this is
where I would go to eat if I was in
Stockholm okay and I went there and it
was insane it was so good yeah the
meatballs right oh my God oh my God I'm
sorry I didn't get to try them yeah I
have two life-changing meals here uh one
was in Denmark and one was in Sweden
meatballs and hot dogs yeah meatballs
and hot dogs literally it was you know
you know when you have one of those
meals where you're like I'm going to
remember this meal for the rest of my
life memory unlocked yeah yeah yeah that
happened twice in the store I have never
personally been a big like meatballs
person
generally they're pretty average for me
yeah but my God these were just these
were just enough yeah they're insane me
and Connor ordered one to share between
us and I wish
yeah because we bought we got like three
menu items they were all pretty good but
the meatballs were just and then dude I
had like a dessert I got like apple pie
best apple pie of my life yeah I had uh
another Glizzy [__] a joke you only
get [__] hot dogs in McDonald's and
honestly Swedish hot dogs also girded
you tried to make this the Americas
okay so unlike in Denmark right where
like you know you have like a shitload
of toppings you can put on it to add
like that much more flavor the Swedish
hot dogs are just like your bog standard
like you know ketchup mustard and you
talk [__] about the Costco the fattest
[__] Glizzy I've seen in my life like
this guy was gothy as [__] with a tiny
tiny bun really cheap as well
um and yeah it was [__] great I knew
the restaurant was going to be good when
I walked in I did not see a single
person under 40 in the restaurant yeah I
I was just like oh this seems like a
place Felix would go to yeah
um but yeah I mean it was I will never
forget
it
thank you for showing us this yeah it
was about that yeah but uh yeah I mean
like I'm going to remember the first
time I had a daily shot dog and now I'm
gonna remember the very first time I had
a Swedish meatball because every time I
have a meatball afterwards I'm going to
compare it to that one and I don't think
it's ever going to match up honestly
like it was like the first time I took
him in I was it just it was just like on
that level
core memory I wanna cry because this
meal is so [__] good and I feel like
I'm unlocking new taste buds now
um yeah it was it was insane yeah I have
nothing bad to say about the meals I had
in Sweden after that actually we should
prefer so that we can give ourselves
some kind of out here sure if people
disagree with our takes we should be
like these are based on just the meals
we had yeah the entire Cuisine yes yeah
absolutely um so you know unfortunate
unfortunately this is gonna to be based
on pure gatchlock and whether we went to
a good restaurant or not yeah so if
you're from this country don't be
offended yeah it was on this list I'm
sure yeah everyone get ready so all
right was Oslo Norway uh which uh I
booked uh I put me and gone a nice
restaurant for lunch and it's pretty
good yeah uh it was it was like how do I
describe it it tasted very healthy is
what I always say what did you get it
was like a sharing experience or
something like yes and they bought some
veal we had speech yeah that was amazing
yeah we had like red beats on uh or with
some special sauce like sauce and some
onions and it sounds so not exciting but
it was really really good it was the
star of the entire like everything that
we got given yeah we had some it was
like sour cream with some really nice
flat bread yeah uh and uh cauliflower
wings so they were like cauliflower that
were cooked like chicken wings it was a
solid meal I think it was not as good as
Sweden and Denmark but I think it was
better for me than Ireland and
Netherlands I think I'd put it egg
basically yeah today I wouldn't disagree
with that unless you think B yeah I
think B you think B yeah
honestly if it was up to me I would read
Netherlands a like I thought it was less
impressive than their croissant oh my
gosh the uh
noodles
did I have noodles we had noodles oh
yeah that was that wasn't the show
though yeah that was in the show I don't
really count that out no take that one
see but that's the problem right is that
this was like right in the middle of
that six show like streak and so we were
constantly just on this like grind of
like okay you know if I can get to the
destination immediately start go you
know go to The Venue try and walk around
for a little bit to see at least a
little bit of the city and then if you
have time you might have see this this
is where the difference in priority lies
Joe you just wanted to explore like the
city and stuff me and Conor are like all
right we need a good meal yeah where we
want to try the local Cuisine I I clown
on the French but I think there's one
part of me that is French and it's the
fact that no matter where I went I was
like I want a [__] three-course meal
I was like I got one hour we can make it
work yeah yeah I just wanted to see the
city I was like what's the highest rated
restaurant that's near walking distance
and is also part of local Cuisine all
right we're going there we're going
there that was that was my experience of
every year country yeah pretty much
would squeeze in uh a lunch like meal
because I thought in my head the way
that I judge if I want to come back to a
country is like do I have did I have
like amazing restaurant experiences
because that then makes me think oh
there's so much good food that I can get
excited for right so I really wanted to
just try some really good food in each
country so that I could think okay when
I come back I know that there's like at
least one good place that I like and
that I'm sure there's reflect of The
Culinary experience yeah I think this
really shows like our differences in how
we treat like visiting a place because
like I'm much more focused on like
sightseeing and just like yeah getting
the vibe of the actual like City or
wherever I am and like the food is for
me is kind of just like optional nah
that's like the stuff
sightseeing I need a nice meal at the
end of the sightseeing because like it's
like when people go to Japan and they're
like oh yeah I'm just gonna eat the
Family Mart sandwiches I'm like at least
get the onigiri
like come on man like at least try yeah
uh okay so what you guys both think B
then okay I'd like if it's up to me uh
Netherlands would be a and uh no it
would be B
I'm gonna say oh man okay well
okay okay how should we do this maybe on
the record I'm saying Norway's a but
fine we can put it in B yeah we'll put
no a n b yeah
um all right all right leads Germany to
Germany Berlin
um the [__] Venus schnitzel I had was
so good it wasn't really that good I I
really liked it but then again I'm a
sucker for Venus schnitzel I'm also easy
to please with German food so yeah all
right so I gotta say I really really
[__] enjoyed the Germany show I
really felt like for once I connected
with the Germans you know like how so I
I was just like you know what your bread
actually [__] goaded I felt like I
felt like I was on a news character Arc
and uh I got a really good reception at
the German show which I was surprising
to me it felt like it felt like uh you
know when you fight the public mask and
we were intending yeah yeah yeah I felt
like uh what's the word I'm looking for
uh not Rehabilitation but uh
what's Rehabilitation yeah it was kind
of Rehabilitation
was they gave his uh yeah me a standing
ovation when I said bread is good I was
I was small I was like very easy yeah
I know Redemption it felt like you know
I had a little Redemption Arc to the
Germans which uh pains me to say that
I'm about to make an enemy of the
Germans again no uh because I I just
started my I just had a Redemption Arc
uh and I gotta say uh so I didn't just
spend a day in Berlin it's been like
five days in cologne as well trying as
much German cuisine as I could sure
I think British Cuisine is better oh I I
know I I think British Cuisine is better
than German cuisine I I genuinely I wait
did you say that on the Germany show no
yeah you would have been murdered
before I judge you uh what are your
reasonings what are my reasoning so a
lot of dishes kind of feel similar to
like to like British like British
Cuisine uh and when I had like a German
like dish something like schnitzel for
example I would just I was just like I'd
rather have fish and chips you know I
I'd rather have like a good fish and
chips the Schnitzel was fine it was fine
I'd rather fish and chips you know um
that's fair I think Germany I I like it
and I like the food Dominic's I'm just
I'm blinded by the bread and the like I
just depressed okay so for when I say
Cuisine you guys beat us in beer and
bread that's not even that's not even a
[__] argument but in just like the
dishes that traditional German dishes
that you had I was just like you know
what I think I think there are more
there's more in a British Cuisine you
know I think a lot of people clown on
British Cuisine and I've had enough
because uh now that I've been abroad I'm
like you know what I actually think I
like British food more as well I mean I
think on average yes yes
I think just because I like so many
meals in Germany I'll get thing I'll get
like a dish yeah and I'll only like the
main part of the Dish everything around
it I'm like I don't really I don't
really care I mean I had a curry worse
and it was probably the worst Curry
worst I've had in Germany I've had I had
two curry wests in Germany and I'm like
this
this is your this is your strongest
Curry this is your this is this this is
your strongest fighter really I'm also
not a fan of like boiled potatoes and
there's so many times you get boiled
potatoes and stuff all potatoes and you
you got the Rosemary and the and the
fluffy inside as well um that being said
that that's like I did I think it was
probably the weakest meal of the tour we
had because I think we just didn't we
didn't go like to the best spot we went
to a beer garden and I felt like it was
just overly touristy and it was just I I
don't I don't think it was like great
food I liked it
the beer was great though I mean the
beer was great the beer was good and it
was it was like the Berlin beer which is
like one of the I think worst ones and
it was still it was still pretty yeah
the weakest beer was still better than
any beers you can get in England
they put all the points in bread and
beer which are essentially just
different forms of each other foreign
I'd be very happy but I think on average
like I would I mean what even is British
British food is so [__] weird British
food is not even a food anymore it's
like well that's why I'm operation of
the fact you guys rate that higher than
the Germans I think British food is the
thing it's like a combination of like a
lot of things I think uh it's very like
one thing people think British food they
think like [__] fish and chips uh
what else do you think anything food
actually from from someone not from
England what do you think when you think
British food uh fish and chips toast
sandwich toast sandwich uh beans okay
actually beans are golden all right
that's that's not [__] talk the beans
here Joe I'm not sure the beans
it's just three things
are American tour manager came to the UK
and they had an English breakfast and
um she showed us I was like can I see a
picture of it and the sausage looked
mummified it looked like it had been
dried for years yeah and the I think
they had like eggs that looked awful it
just looked terrible it's good I was
like this looks [__] hot really yeah
it was a nightmare see it's easy to just
post a picture of like a shitty British
me on being like ah the British have no
taste but you know I I think and you
know now that you know traveling around
I really rate our [__] pasties and I
think our Savory pastries to be fair yes
I do rate that [__] anything you can
get in Greg's man
how did we talk how does that always
happen we talk about Germany it comes
back to the UK
Island Amsterdam and Norway were better
than Germany the meals we had yeah I
don't [__] remember anything I had in
Amsterdam nowhere I went to the dolls
it's your fault that is your fault all
right so what Cod guys uh are we gonna
put anything in D because I I don't
think I have anything else that would
guarantee no I'll put it C then oh yeah
I'll put it so I can't believe he's not
being used is it yeah I guess these not
being used I did feel wrong to put
something in detail and put Germany in
deep no Deutschland
put UK in Celsius
I had an amazing Curry the other night
yeah London that was great yeah I did a
really good at expanding day we
sometimes use the spices that we stole
yeah you know that's that's one
accounts
yeah I think I I honestly I I always
have feel like I enjoy my meals in the
UK
I honestly think that the quality of a
lot okay it's very different though
actually London is different
um but you know I generally think the
quality of food in England has just gone
up uh as time's gone by I Just Disagree
that Irish food was better than than
stuff in London okay yeah actually I
just can't actually
this is why I said Island should go and
see you can't believe me okay yeah yeah
you're right I I was I had Guinness on
my mind you know
I just I just wanted to put Guinness on
there let's be honest but yeah I think
that okay I'm gonna now make a enemy of
the Irish uh I think UK food was better
than the Ireland food as well okay so as
well Joey don't don't look at yeah
okay to be fair you recommended me like
the new uh so I've had Greg's once
before this yeah it was I just had like
a sausage roll
um which is fine it's good uh but the
one you recommended yeah the [__]
beans cheese and sausage pasty was it
that's the one yeah yeah that was bomb
yeah
um so where's the UK going I think it's
going Hi-C I think it's I don't think
it's on the same level as other European
countries right now but if we're taking
on the Germans and the Irish uh I think
we're better I I think we're better and
I'm sticking with that and I don't care
if that's the hot take of the day okay
but I think UK I think UK food should uh
it's it's not a high tier Cuisine I'm
not gonna call it that but it's
definitely not as low as the entire
world says it is you know you think you
know we've got Sunday roasts we got
[__] um afternoon tea as well also
like I think full English breakfast
pasties yeah we've got good sausages
here that's the one yeah I I think it's
it's way better than people giving
credit for I've turned around and see
I've I've never been to India but out of
all the places where I've had Indian
food the UK is normally my favorite
place to have it
I mean that's just like it could be a
bad take yes
which uh is known for having no foods
normally well yeah the producers here
are probably pretty pretty vocal about
their feelings on it uh to be fair the
burger I had was pretty [__]
well food no it was food whilst food
really struggles to find an identity I
think
um
it's sheep uh well lamb uh leek uh and
cakes typically none of which you had
guys
um mainly because you're in Cardiff and
Cardiff is like the least Welsh place in
Wales right
um it really did just feel like England
2.0 Yeah well yeah Cardiff is just an
extensioners because it's so close to
England and it's also a major city and
historical reasons but uh I think I mean
honestly I don't even think we had a
burger we had a burger and a regular
wrap which is like from an African
restaurant I mean I think I it was about
the same as Irish or maybe less than
Irish food I think it the Germans would
be so pissed off to have it higher but I
think it's yeah I mean let's piss off
the Germans
higher than D or ID or low [__]
[__] the Germans oh my God so yeah I
would admit I was wrong about your bread
but I'm sticking with this new tank I
have British Cuisine yeah
uh solos German cuisine
that's so unbelievably cap I couldn't
believe what you just said oh my God
this episode is sponsored by boxu boxer
delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
teas sourced directly from centuries old
small family businesses right to your
door their mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world every single box who is packed
to the brim with some amazingly rare
snacks that are really hard to find in
Japan each box who also comes with a
cultural booklet informing you all about
the snacks Origins and flavors when you
order a box too the first box you'll
receive is the seasons of Japan
following that every single month you'll
receive a newly monthly themed box
normally tying into some cultural aspect
in Japan I get one of these every single
month and I love it if you're like me
and you love rice crackers most boxes
include sembe which is one of my
favorite Japanese snacks and it's
something you'll most certainly gonna
need to try and they also have a tea
pairing which goes with some of the
snacks and trust me
it's so good so what are you waiting for
smash that link in the description down
below right now to get 15 off your own
boxu Japanese snack box and support our
Channel and use our code trash taste at
boxu.com that's
b-o-k-k-s-u.com that is
b-o-k-k-s-u.com with code trash taste
for 15 off your very first order thank
you to boxu for sponsoring the show back
to the episode how did you guys find the
shows dude it was crazy because it's
like I think you know after we did the
America shows we obviously with an
American crowd right like we knew they
were going to be Rowdy because they're
[__] Americans yeah the Americans
will cheer for anything they will cheer
for literally anything and they did and
so like you know our producers were
saying like oh you know especially up in
like Scandinavia but a lot of parts of
Europe they might be a little more
reserved so it might be some quieter
show so you're gonna maybe require a
little bit more riling up of the crowd
to really get them into the the move
um but no uh I I think just our fans are
just [__] wild yeah anywhere in the
world because so we were warned before
by our like tour staff that you know we
should expect kind of more of more
reserved crowd especially in like the
Scandinavian countries where you know
they have this kind of like philosophy I
can't remember I think it's like the law
of jonte or something where you know
it's it's kind of like they have to be
think that are not better than anyone
and be like like humble right very
humble yeah
um there there were some of the like the
European crowd I we did not have a
single quiet crowd everyone was like on
average I think they were louder than
the American yeah
sorry Americans actually I think the
Europeans were actually louder I don't
know if it's just because they had like
one night just to really let loose and
let it go I I I think it's because like
you know in America you have such a
vast choice of options it's like
somebody's into more Niche Hobbies like
anime or gaming to kind of have
opportunities to really uh express
yourself go to events with like-minded
people uh and feel like you're in a
comfortable space people to like Express
and yeah a little wild and I think going
to Europe and kind of bringing this show
format and what we talk about well we
have like a [__] 10 minute segment on
hentai like I think like no other show
is doing that obviously in in
Scandinavian so I think it's like it's
kind of like a fun vibe where it's like
[__] yeah I can just [__] like watch
a show from something I would never get
to watch I think it's also due to the
fact that you know like I think that the
main consensus is like oh there's always
like tools and like shows and stuff like
that in America right because that's
like the Hub to do shows like that yeah
very rarely do like you know YouTubers
or like any kind of like stage shows
actually do tours in Europe so like the
few times that it does happen everyone
gets hyped up I know because it's
exactly the same in Australia right like
every time I see like a famous artist
that's doing like a world tour and
they're not stopping in Australia I'm
just like what the [__] this is [__]
because when they do come to Australia
it is hype as [__] so I totally get it
yeah I mean I also think uh so there's a
big drinking culture in Europe as well
yes uh and one thing I found funny was
when we performed in the Apollo uh in
England it was the only venue we've ever
done where we had it was contractual for
us to take a 20-minute intermission now
you might be wondering why do we need to
take a 20-minute intermission what's up
what's up with that why is it on the
contract well it's so that people can go
out and buy drinks that is the most
British thing I've ever heard in my life
now guys guys you need to stop the show
so people can get more [__] pissed
yeah yeah they need they need some time
to top up yeah not even Ireland did that
yeah not even Ireland did that yeah yeah
but Ireland they pre-load it so they
everyone would come in
this is one dude Rock someone Fork
innocent sits down and he's like I'm
ready
for your mates he's like no for me it's
like damn boys committed he's timed it
out yeah I feel like the speed run every
30 minutes yeah yeah he had like two in
the VIP and then enduring VIP he he went
out and got four so he had six
guinnesses
I remember he asked his question and
then the moment he was finished he was
like all right I'm gonna head out yeah
yeah
what do you think was the rowdiest crowd
of all of them oh and also it does the I
what I realized is that absolutely the
day of the week very much to talk very
much absolutely if it's a Saturday
obviously it's gonna be a lot louder and
it's a Monday it's gonna be a lot
quieter but yeah you still get a I think
the one that sticks out to me the most
was probably the Germany show oh Germans
were rare I think uh the wandering Rowdy
I think I think the one in uh London
obviously had an advantage because it
was the biggest show we've ever done by
a thousand like by about like 1 500
people I think uh but I think in terms
of like average person being the loudest
uh it's probably the Germans yeah it's
so loud I think Rotterdam was pretty
damn loud
Amsterdam was loud Amsterdam was also
allowed in Sweden Emerald yeah
yeah like like we said we didn't have a
quiet show there was no choir show there
was loud uh or [__] you you got like
uh uh you lost your hearing at the end
of the show that was kind of it um but
one thing I liked about show is that you
know we do this show and we get to learn
a little bit about our countries as well
and I think Alex our content producer
killed it because of the first game we
you know we had a bunch of questions
related yes during the uh trash taste uh
America Tour that we released it's kind
of a similar format but we changed the
first game yep
um to kind of focus more on the places
the country that we're in and we found
out what people got uh patriotic about
yeah uh the biggest cheer in the German
show uh was finding out that they have a
childhood mascot which is like a
depressed piece of bread
they lost it they were wild
it wasn't burnt dust Bros yeah but
that's brought or something like that
they [__] lost it yeah oh my God it's
Birds
I've never seen people react to a
childhood mascot that violence I've
never seen a child in Mascot that looks
like that looks like this as well of
course it's German
because I used to go to when I was
growing up my dad worked in Germany a
lot so I'd go to Germany all the time
and I remember whenever we used to go to
any of the like middle European
countries they always had the [__]
ugliest cartoons always the ugliest
cartoons and look at this [__]
horrific thing could you imagine looking
at this be like oh yes my childhood
the bread with warts
and a unibrow the way that because they
designed him with like the most
atrocious eye bags possible this is a
man who's watched NTR and has lived to
see another day you know look at that
[__]
um I found out you know as a Brit what
US Brits get the most patriotic about uh
it's not football it's not football yeah
uh it's when Henry the Hoover got shown
on screen and got a standing ovation
yeah dude Henry the Hoover
what was your reaction to seeing uh or
did you even know what uh what Henry was
no when it came up no I didn't like I
for one I'd never seen it before I think
I said in the show it looks like the
[__] thing in Teletubbies that feeds
them the the costume
yeah but then it was [__] wild
because that night when we got back to
the hotel uh there was a dude vacuuming
and it was [__] Henry's and it had
the name Henry on it and I'm just like
oh my gosh this is actually everywhere
if you want a vacuum that doesn't break
the Henry on yeah that like no tourists
are being did you guys have a Henry yeah
I did but then you kind of yeah this is
a classic video
yeah like no choice for like being very
good but they'd often lose suction after
a while but it's it's the one Hoover you
normally see in uh every like
establishment has one
um most uni Halls have one because it's
like pretty cheap compared to like other
vacuum cleaners as well and uh I didn't
realize this until going living outside
of the UK that I've only seen it in the
UK yeah and you don't notice it but once
once you point it out you realize oh you
see Henry everywhere everywhere yeah
yeah it's crazy because even like there
were there was a lot of people who went
to our show who flew in from abroad or
something and they were like I was so
confused and then I saw so many posts
and replies to my Twitter thread being
like holy [__] I see Henry in my [__]
hotel oh my God he's right there that
follows me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
oh there is a Harry oh my God I didn't
know so I was right yeah so you won't
even see the red one though yeah you'll
see the red one so uh we are so the
question was on uh on the stage of the
show uh what was the name of this
British icon yeah and for some reason
Joey answers Harry yeah I didn't know
there was a Harry Potter technically I
got it right no no you said Norman I was
going to say Harry but I was like no
that's dumb
yeah and we felt like it's it's so it's
so weird uh funny all about other
different cultures as well we found out
that uh the Dutch have like their own
ticks they're like
right they you know like teachers don't
do like this got a [__] massive cheer
but yeah I didn't know they don't have
their own like a tick is too much effort
apparently no it's too little it's too
little actually they needed to really
extravagant swirl yeah
it looks like a really fancy end sign
it's like yeah yeah yeah I can't
remember what the exact name of it was
um but then they also we also found out
about the uh yeah that's it that's it
wow that's such a nice name yeah of
approval
yeah I don't know what how this became a
thing uh but that's that's very fancy
and uh unlocked a lot of cool memories I
love it you Google Dutch Tech
alternative that came up with pets
I just don't like the normal ticks
alternative things
all those texts also Dutch people uh
what the [__] is up with your toilets
why oh my God yeah yeah I didn't come
across so that's true there was one at
the the venue what's the Dutch toilet
okay so you know how normally yeah that
one yeah the one you know how normally
the the bowl is kind of like water the
water bowl is right underneath your ass
yeah
Dutch toilets for some reason it's like
right in front of you like this yeah so
it's just like a little water slide for
your [__] yeah it's like a splashback
countermeasure no no you get you get
splashback because from the ship because
because the the ceramic is so close to
your ass that you sometimes you get
[__] splashback if it's not yeah yeah
yeah and then when you go to wipe your
ass you have to like make eye contact
with your [__] because it's just right
here
you have to risk you're above seeing
your own [__] Joe
um you know what I'm good
you know I want to look at it
and uh
is it to you you inspect your ship hi
you know so the Dutch love looking each
other you should see it you got to see
it I'm sure but too quick are we to not
appreciate the wonders of plumbing and
flush it away I actually can gauge if my
[__] is good while it's coming out I
don't need to see it well you know
sometimes when it's coming out you're
like oh this is a bad one I don't even
need to see it I know that's a bad one
yeah and then sometimes it's so clean
just swish doesn't even touch the room
you know uh what else happened in
Amsterdam I feel like there was other
stuff that oh you speak of toilets I
went to um and when we were in Rotterdam
there's a game uh that I've played a
bunch
um called uh we were here or uh we were
together or something it's I guess if we
were here and there's like a bunch of
puzzle games and the game devs are in uh
Rotterdam right and so they invited uh
me and reinho to go and play uh the game
she went she went to the studio
they were super chill everyone was
really nice and I asked him I was like
hey so what's the uh where's the toilet
at and they're like oh yeah just just
got together she was like oh and don't
worry about the what's in there I was
like what what do you mean don't worry
about it okay so I walk in and I I open
the toilet and I'm like huh and I look
up and there's a noose hanging from the
top of the toilet and I was like uh what
yeah it was a noose a noose on on top of
the toilet and I I go outside and I'm
like Hey so uh what's the deal with the
Noose and they were like oh
um crunch time
I was like man I know you guys are
working for rock stars
they said it was a Halloween decoration
and I was like from like two months
early or yeah from from 10 months ago so
yeah it was a Halloween decoration but
it was a very funny image I took a
picture it looks it looks so funny
because it's just a toilet with a noose
coming down from it and I was like wow
that's a that's
it was very funny but they were already
Sweet and that was that was cool that's
kind of when I like touring the most is
when we get to kind of do these cool
opportunities that because I would never
be in Rotterdam I would never go to
Rotterdam otherwise like there's no
reason I would ever be there uh unless I
was just there casually and I feel like
then I if I was there casually I
wouldn't mention it right I wouldn't
make a big deal about it yeah so it's
really cool that's what I really like
about doing the tourism to kind of do
these really interesting experiences
that you never would have the chance to
do yeah because like I feel like having
you know we had sometimes less than a
day in the city but it's weird sometimes
you just get the vibe of the city and a
place like if you get a Vibe of like if
you'd want to come back you know like
for example I've
I could see myself coming back to I
think like I think Copenhagen I really
want to come back to uh try out all of
the hot dogs as well uh I think a place
like mostly the hot dogs yeah I think a
place like Oslo I got the vibe and if I
go back to Norway I'd rather go far up
north yeah you know rather than going to
the city I think I'd rather explore the
rest uh of Norway yeah uh one one place
that really stuck out to me was
Stockholm just because like I kind of
got the chance to actually like go into
the city center and like kind of very
green go around it's it was beautiful
like very very traditional like kind of
Old Europe style
um I went to like a bunch of record
stores in Stockholm and it was just like
the vibe was like perfect yeah and I'm
just like I want to come back here and
actually like you know maybe go to like
you know the outskirts of Sweden stuff
like that actually go see the
countryside I think it'd be really dope
also I don't know if it was just like uh
a subliminal thing but for some reason I
stepped out of the airport in Stockholm
and I'm like I think this is the
cleanest air I've ever breathed in my
life in a city I don't I don't know it
just it just fell super [__] I don't
know don't you have like a
like
I think I think it was something there
was some factoid or something that it
was like yeah Sweden has uh like the
greenest cities in the world like it was
just so clean and like pristine and but
like it still kind of had that like
liveliness of a big city and it was just
I don't know how they did it but you
guys did it yeah fun vibe yeah honestly
we didn't go to a place that was bad
that's all probably because we didn't
stop off in Paris you know yes uh yeah I
mean we were like so to any French
people to went to our shows we are sorry
but also you know we have to play to the
crowd yeah we're coming come on
apparently everyone in Europe uh loves
the clown on France oh they love clowns
yeah yeah especially uh French cuisine
as well yeah French cuisine because
there's a river question in the show
that was uh we'd ask the audience uh to
fill out a QR codes like in the the
American tour yeah we'd ask them which
country has the most overrated Cuisine
and without fail France was number one
what's even close yeah sometimes it was
like 50 of the vote or four times the
next one it was like it was pretty
impressive how universally people agreed
that French food was overrated you know
what surprised me though because we we
talk about French food being number one
in every show but I'll tell you what was
also in every show Oh yeah Italian food
being second yeah every show the Italian
every single European country agreed
that uh Italian food was overrated which
is weird yeah that's a weird take I've
never heard anyone say they thought
Italian food was overrated yeah like
what about Italian food is overrated I
don't know maybe it's just everyone just
likes it Pizza Pasta overrated maybe
because it's just so you know you can
get it anywhere and it's been so
commercialized I mean granted you know
not every like Italian restaurant I've
been to has been like [__] 10 out of
10 or anything like sure there's some
bad Italian restaurants but like I've
never thought it to be like overrated
yeah no no that's a different vibe you
know I was also impressed by uh we asked
the audience as well in every show name
which anime they thought had the worst
fandom and I don't know how how do they
all just do this every single show said
my hero Academia how do they all know
this every single how do they as number
one I just like how do they all come
together and have this all collective
experience or are they also almost every
single one second place was one piece
not everyone though not everyone almost
not everybody not everyone it was always
top three always top three that's I mean
that didn't surprise me so much why is
my hero always like why my future
surprised me the most because I thought
I thought everyone thought that most
people are just stopped watching my
heroes I had to have a fan base
they definitely are not the most vocal
fan base anymore
um yeah because I was surprised because
uh Demon Slayer never never got out
there Demon Slayer never got up there
it's too generic you know uh like you
just guys never got up there either uh
that sometimes fate got up there a few
times
came together to uh clown on my hero
Academia fans and God knows they're
taking enough else guys come on like do
we really need to give them another one
the show is already pretty rough it's
not doing well
what season are we [__] on right now
like six or something seven seven we're
going on season seven yeah yeah yeah
that was the Seven Seasons yeah and it
sucks because season six was the best
season in a long time no and then
everyone's still clowning on them I was
like nice
oh man you hate to see it you hate to
see it I try on the best but how was it
um for you guys you guys got to play in
front of you know your home crowd you
know Wales and London like how was that
for you guys yeah
um I was [__] so to me like I've
never seen you that nervous
uh yeah I was I wasn't like okay so
there's like two kind of like nervous
right there's one where you're kind of
like dreading it and there's one where
you just want to do it you're gonna be
on there you want to be on there uh and
you just want it to be the best thing it
can be sure I got like the second kind
of nerve as well I was just like it was
it was my home you know my home country
all of my friends and family were there
I had like I think over half of the
people that attended my wedding were at
this show oh [__]
um so like so many of my family members
were there so I just wanted to get on
and make sure that it was like the best
that it can be and more importantly that
I was like in top form as well uh and
yeah I think the London show was [__]
incredible but it was surreal like
performing in front of friends and
family uh
yeah I was trying I was trying to think
back because we like do you guys have a
routine when you go on at all do you
guys have like a way to like mentally
prep yourself well you've you played
chess this time I should just I just sit
there I just I'm just like all right I'm
just trying to talk yeah I'm gonna talk
so much for two hours yeah one one thing
because one thing I did realize is that
talking before the show actually makes
it worse for me really you know I'd
rather sit in silence the hour before
the show uh but when I had like this
many friends and family I was just like
all right guys I'm gonna talk for five
minutes and then I'm gonna go I'm sorry
I I need time to like decompress and
just like get in like the right mental
state before getting on stage but it was
just so yeah because we hadn't seen our
friends in so long and they were super
super excited to talk yeah yeah I'm I'm
[__] holding my chi right now
I can't I'll talk to you guys after this
year give me five minutes it's like one
percent of my power yeah it's like
Naruto like [__] sage mode where he
has to sit still and not be touched
that's like me before going on stage but
it's such a weird thing to explain to
you because I guess if you've never done
it you've been on stage before if you've
ever been on stage of Philly you'd
probably relate to it
um because you just need that you just
need to focus I don't know why yeah you
need to like not think and just just
have a blank slate when you go out there
yeah so you can push everything onto it
yeah um I don't really have like a
routine or anything if anything I think
sitting in silence for me makes me more
nervous right because like it makes me
think about oh I have to go on stage
whereas if I'm talking to someone just
chatting and bantering then it kind of
distracts me from the fact that I need
to go on and so when the time you know
when it is time to go up on stage I'm
like oh okay it's time yeah and then I'm
nervous for maybe like you know 30
seconds before we go on and then I'm
good yeah but if I sit there in silence
then then I'm just going to be
ruminating over the fact that it's like
okay I gotta nail This I Gotta nail This
I Gotta make sure this joke hits I gotta
make sure this all goes well and it just
I think it just adds more pressure yeah
in a weird way I don't know it's weird
yeah I mean I think everyone I've you
know where you realize that every
everyone has a different kind of like
approach into especially like a high
pressure moment because I I attribute it
it's gonna sound like a weird [__]
comparison but I attribute it to uh
doing my final exams in uni right
okay okay so like you have like you have
like two hours and all of your year has
led up to this one moment and you've
studied for it hopefully hopefully
you've studied for it but you know that
the last 10 minutes no matter how much
you try to cram none of it's gonna stick
in so like for me the best thing the
best thing I tried to do before going
into my final exams was just like
[__] chill out and try to calm my
mind yeah so that that was kind of like
the same kind of mental state as I had
when I was gonna go on stage performing
it's like a it's like competing if
you've ever competed anything like and
you've cared a lot about it yeah it's
like 10 minutes before you have to go
and do the match or something you're
like oh okay all right yeah yeah like
hold my energy and I gotta feel like I
focused when I get out there it's kind
of like that too yeah but after a while
I mean we've done the show
30 plus times now 33 33 times I could do
it in my sleep yeah yeah I mean
definitely like I think now it's just
like kind of in our system now where we
don't even really think about it anymore
yeah you know I feel the shows some
instances have got a little bit scarfed
the sense
this episode of trash days is sponsored
by Mint mobile signing your life away to
a big wireless provider is kind of like
being trapped on a roller coaster from
Hell which for Joey is every roller
coaster sure it looks fun at first they
probably threw in a free phone but now
you can't get off month after month of
insane bills and unexpected Thrills like
overages and surprise fears if that
sounds like your current big Wireless
plan it's time to get off that ride with
mint mobile for a limited time Wireless
plans for me mobile are just 15 a month
did you hear that boys 15 a month that's
unlimited talk text and data for just 15
a month guys million dollars here to
rescue you with premium Wireless plans
for just 15 bucks a month so bye bye to
your big Wireless plans jewelry dropping
monthly bills and unexpected overages
all plans come with unlimited talks and
techs plus high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network so use
your phone with any mobile plan and
bring your phone number along with all
your existing contacts I saved a lot
using mint mobile for a limited time
Wireless plans for Mid mobile are just
15 a month that's unlimited talk text
and data for just 15 a month and get
your plan shipped to your door for free
go to midmobile.com trash that's
mintmobile.com trash got your wireless
bill to 15 bucks
trash back to the episode so yeah how
was it for you perform in front of your
parents it was fun
um my my parents and two of my brothers
came to the uh Dublin show which was uh
fun I think they were more excited to go
to Dublin than Wales but it didn't come
to Wales again to Dublin but actually
it's about it's about the same time to
get to each yeah because you can just
get the uh the ferry from North Wales
yeah uh over so it's pretty easy to get
there and I think they all just like
going to Ireland I mean Island's nice so
yeah how was it performing uh in Wales
yeah Wales was cool and well the Welsh
crowd was definitely uh I think because
it was a Monday it was definitely some
really loud people and then some people
who were very quiet and it was it was
fun trying to get their energy out of
them sometimes but it was a smaller show
as well to be fair yeah there was a
small show but they they were still loud
at times
um it was good I think I was definitely
more nervous performing in front of my
parents than in front of Welsh people
yeah Welsh people I'm like yeah let's
[__] go let's do it yeah
um but yeah and in front of my parents
it was it was interesting all right
because there's one part on the show
where we've to name a hentai category we
secretly like and uh that was what I was
nervous about as well yeah you mention
like a pawn category ratio that you like
yeah yeah and I was like well I should
probably shouldn't say MILF
yeah so I I I didn't say it was the only
time I ever didn't say milk yeah I was
like all right well it was funny what
did you say you said vanilla or
something yeah of course yeah because I
did it on London show as well missionary
of course only yeah
post marital yeah
because yeah they loved it though they
really liked it yeah because uh I think
what made me more nervous on the day of
like the London show was I had like the
guest list of like friends and family
and like in the most like big Asian
family way possible I get like a message
about like six hours before the show and
they're like oh a cousin just said he's
free uh he wants to come to the show
yeah God your family was like 900 people
and then like progressively they were
like oh wait another cousin is also free
oh another cousin's coming actually and
I I think I had like an extra six to
seven people just like progressively in
the day being like actually uh family
I'm free so dude it was crazy like
throughout the entire day it was just
like a posse of people just like rocking
up and I'm like what the [__]
it's like how many are there back here
yeah
um and you know a lot of them but I
pretty much every one of them uh did not
know anything about trash Chase all
those shows
um I had I had one cousin that I had not
seen in about like a decade just because
we've always we'd like we've all he's
been living in different countries so
we've never kind of like matched up so
he was like actually on there on the day
and it was the first time I've seen in
him in over a decade uh last time we'd
kind of like talked I did not do YouTube
or you know still I think this was like
still when I was in university yeah not
even this was like pre-bbc errors so
when he heard I was doing a show in
London he assumed it was nine and a half
pounds
your school band yeah he thought he
thought I was like doing a [__] band
performance in London you know we did we
did get our friends good kid to open for
us at the London show yeah should have
just got nine and a half pounds
yeah yeah so he was like oh what what
you're not doing a music show this isn't
a band what are you guys doing and I was
just like oh my God we have so much to
catch on how do I even begin to explain
what we're doing right now
comedy show yeah but I was impressed
because pretty much everyone enjoyed
themselves even if they have no interest
in anime mango or YouTube it's like I
think we when we were making the tour
that's one thing we said something
America Tour thing as well we're like
yeah we just want to make sure that
anyone could watch it yeah yeah
um but if you're a fan of trash testing
yeah there's like added bonuses right
yeah yeah but I think again knowing that
our parents really enjoyed really
enjoyed their time there uh I think also
parents like it's just kind of a cool
experience just go like backstage and
then be like hang out and just be like
all right go do a suit now someone will
help you you know yeah it's such a
phonics I think it's like a cool
experience because like like a lot of
people just don't get to do that as well
oh yeah totally so I think well my
parents I know my Mom and Dad loved that
they were like I was like what we get to
have free beers yeah well it's obvious
it's not free but yep it's free for you
it was a totally different experience
for me I had like
small Asian family
and everyone's like let's take a picture
and I'm like okay how many different
combinations am I taking today ah okay
it was kind of ridiculous I was like oh
my God I was like God's family came out
like five people and I was like oh
that's nice and four more Thai people
came out yeah five more Thai people five
more types
I didn't even take them to the green
room because uh the queen room would not
fit my family so I just took them out
back by them but even without your
family two of the green rooms were just
completely full I'm just like what the
[__] yeah but uh yeah that's why the
London show meant a lot to me and I'm
glad to say that it's uh went out really
well yeah it's uh I'm glad to see I
actually I actually have a pretty funny
story of something that happened not
during the tour but this was like before
the tour
so I can't okay I get a message from my
mom right so I got a message from my mom
being like all excited uh because my dad
had just come home and apparently he was
shopping in town uh and someone someone
looked at him and he was just like oh
that's an interesting shirt you're
wearing uh why why are you wearing the
shirt and uh he was like oh I'm uh my
son's a YouTuber and with zero context
but the the shop clerk was like oh is
your is is your son gigock and he was
like yeah how could you know I'm like
you took a picture and I was like I I
asked my mum mum how did he know of that
uh uh that my dad was in town or how
could he guess that I was the son so
this is the shirt that my dad
I was rude and I'll send this to you I
can't believe your dad wore that shirt I
can't believe he wore that yeah
it says insert oppa here it is uh one of
my old shirts that uh one of my old meme
shirts that I had like just lying about
and my dad just like decided to wear it
and go into town when you're dead rocked
up to the show he's wearing the the
purple shirt I always wanted oh he was
he was yeah he got that drip down hell
yeah he's like your number one fan oh he
is now yeah he's so on board I love it I
love how intuitive yeah every time we
get a new must drop my dad like give me
everything
one thing I was nervous about though was
uh not my dad but my cousin uh wanted to
bring my nephew over and I was like a
very much warning my cousin yo at
certain points in the show please take
them out because because
yeah it is not appropriate uh for their
age
um but it was it was weird seeing how
you know it was oddly made me proud as
an uncle being like [__] he is really
[__] excited and like being able to
show him the bus I was like yeah
oh [__] the tour bus was always like I
think impresses people the most
absolutely because it's just so it's so
hard to believe a bus can be so
comfortable yeah and like so I guess and
it's like you guys enjoyed to different
countries
so it was it was like it was it was such
like a wholesome moment for me because
normally he's like a he's like a really
shy kid I kind of like me when I was a
kid super shy doesn't say much when he
was on the bus he was asking like a
million questions oh that's so cute oh
that's so cute man yeah uh yeah honestly
amazing experience doing it in front of
my friends and family I think like this
it kind of felt like a lot of the tour
was like me like preparing for you know
performing in front of my friends and
family totally I'm sure for you as well
for the well show and Performing fun of
like your friends and family as well I
guess our first show was on from my
parents so I kind of was just like I
remember how to do this yeah no you guys
both questions luckily it all worked out
as a really fun show I mean Dublin's
just a great the Dublin is a very fun
city to be in yeah the people are so fun
though yeah and I think yeah I was just
glance I haven't seen uh I haven't seen
that much with my family all in one
place in a while so yeah yeah so it was
really cool real question is are you
gonna want to perform in Australia well
that's the question we've been getting
isn't it like now that we've done a tour
in America because I'm assuming your
parents are going to go to that right I
mean I assume so unless my dad's like no
I can't be [__] no I don't think
they'll say that people do a one-off
show in Australia
like again like the biggest question
we've been getting now that we've
finished the European tour is like well
Asia tour next and yeah if that's the
case we have to go to Australia I think
uh we'd have to figure out I think we
kind of figured out in Europe the Europe
to how much harder Logistics was
compared to America yeah which is like
the merch because you can't travel with
merch across borders otherwise you pay
taxes yeah so you get it delivered and
obviously when you're as you all know if
you've ever lived in Europe deliveries
are not uh Reliant reliable at all yeah
so one of the shows the the merch guys
[__] up and we almost weren't able to
serve them and I was uh Rotterdam yeah
Rotterdam or Amsterdam I can't remember
maybe it was Denmark
one of the drivers of the delivery
company missed the shipment uh so our
our [__] team I actually like I want
to Big it up to our team who were
[__] goaded and sorted out somehow so
professional so they hired someone to
take seven or ten or something a
ridiculous amount of the boxes
17 boxes of merch on a plane
two amps oh no no two Denmark sorry
um so we can get to our show on time
because we were this close to not having
like any merch of that show because
that's how you kind of make a lot of the
shows profitable and make sense to do
yeah because a lot of the times that's
how I'm sure you all know if you've
watched music yeah
and uh they somehow managed to make it
happen uh and that wasn't even like one
of the most impressive things because we
found out uh I think three days before
our Cardiff show that our venue has oh
yeah
just closed it just closed it was so
funny so I was sitting on the bus and I
I haven't used the BBC News app in a
long time because it they changed it and
the layout of it is now [__] and so I
stopped using it because it was so
annoying to navigate yeah and for some
reason I was on the back of the bus and
we were in we're on our way to the
Berlin show and I uh and the the uh one
of our tour staffers in the back with us
and I was just scrolling on it and I saw
this news article that said and it was
posted two minutes ago it was like Saint
David's hole closed in Wales and I was
like huh
what's uh sure sounds like the venue
that we're performing in but let's just
put the poster real quick but saying
David's in Wales that's everywhere he's
saying this he's like our only dude yeah
so I was like well let's have a look
where it is it's like Saint David's
holding Cardiff and I was like oh maybe
there's two holes in Cardiff because
we're having a show in a few days
there's no way it's closing yeah and
then I look up online I was like oh yep
that's our venue yeah it's close uh and
the reason why it was closed is because
in the UK right now there's this whole
thing where there there's a big scare
going on because some buildings used
aerated concrete which I'd never heard
of until this yeah which my god
um
UK construction man I mean
of course we would use that because we
we also use like an ungodly amount of
asbestos as well yeah so so what so what
why why
it's cheaper yeah obviously if you use
less concrete and then it's aerated it's
cheaper but it's also more brutal it's
ridiculous yeah so the venue was shot
and I can't I think it was a brief
moment we all thought oh well I guess
the tour's finishing in London yeah yeah
because it just seemed like it was
logistically impossible to get a show
and wow we have three days to find and
set up a new venue which is like
normally an impossible yeah because we
you know we we had a venue that was 1200
yeah and there's you can't just transfer
that size but like I think luckily we
did we'd sold less tickets which is
normally not a lucky thing but it worked
out that we could find another venue
last minute yeah yeah and yeah all over
the university right yeah the students
union yeah uni which is kind of fun
because it was actually like a really
cozy venue
to the audience even though there was
700 people there totally it was almost
said enough to the show it was nice like
chill Vibe going back to UNI everyone in
Wales was super nice yeah as well big up
to my my Welsh viewers uh you guys were
by far and it wasn't I mean you had some
competition but everyone was super super
polite yeah totally like I was going in
and out of the venue a lot and people
were like oh hi Connor yeah and they
would just be like oh have a nice day
and they'd hold the door open for me and
stuff and I was like oh dude what the
heck no not that like um it's because
like sometimes we were running and being
rushing and I feel bad when I would be
like I can't I can't stop and talk I'm
sorry they're like oh go ahead yeah good
good boss boys yeah one one thing I
found funny when we were in Wales
actually is when we went to uh Cardiff
uh Cardiff Castle
and there was one super proud Welshman
there just like telling us the history
uh because we're talking about how we
were performing and our venue had like
closed down due to structural issues and
he was talking about well you should
have just [__] performed here you
know yeah and he's been like we've been
we've been invaded by the English the
Romans we've invaded so many times they
kicked our ass and we're still here and
they're like oh yeah
[Music]
and I'm like What's the cap of this
place like 20. I realize how I don't
come across as well at all because
people kept asking me they're like it's
your first time in Wales really yeah in
all the stores I went to and I was like
no I guess it's because you've got lost
your accent well I never had a Welsh
accent but I don't sound Welsh and I was
like yeah no no Welsh she's like oh cool
like like I think I actually sort of the
one store clerk and I got I knew right
away she thought I was doing that
American thing where like you say like
oh no I'm like I'm Irish
oh that's nice and I was like no but I
didn't say anything else but on my head
I was like no I speak the language
America
what else child as well she's against
you know what I will say I do enjoy
traveling especially to European
countries with Americans because they
are so like they are so easily impressed
oh my God and it was just Jess Jesse our
tour manager everywhere she went she was
just a bright eyes like she was like I
[__] love it here like I am so
jealous of their energy because you know
growing up in English it's like yes sir
it's a [__] Castle yeah we've got so
many I love Newcastle yeah yeah and
every time they'd see anything in Europe
it's just like oh my God that's so
amazing
like like we uh we were we were walking
around Copenhagen uh and our tour
manager was so [__] enamored with
like this European city with Copenhagen
that uh we went to I believe like
another Castle there or something
uh and there was this uh Danish like God
like you know one of the traditional
Danish guards there and uh he was just
like marching like he had he had a gun
uh which he was like carrying this gun
like a baby yeah I've never seen someone
handle gun passions so delicately yeah
yeah and uh he was just he was just like
marching uh across like the castle uh
and a tour manager goes oh my God just
look at the way he walks he puts One
Foot In Front of the other foot it's
just she's amazing and I'm like Jesse
that's uh just typically how people will
just describe
oh wow they look they look like British
ones what the [__] where did they steal
was like hugging this [__] like AK
yeah and it was it was crazy
it was like a
yeah
I mean it's it's kind of it's got to be
really cool seeing how you travel a few
hours and it's a completely different
culture yeah totally yeah I mean I think
I think one thing that I've always
always felt and one thing I've always
kind of tried to explain is that I think
the vastness of America is lost on
Americans a lot of the time too it's so
big and you and it's really hard to
appreciate that there are differences in
America but I think just because of how
kind of you you all are so insular yet
so separate at the same time like the
fact that it's a six hour flight from
one side of America to the other is
insane yeah it's such it's such a large
country yeah but that being said when
you go to Europe you're like I drove an
hour and there's a different country a
different culture and different
languages it's so it's gonna be such a
freaking for me the concept of just
driving to another country is so foreign
to me Australia because Australia and
Japan can't do that [__] you know yeah
so it was really cool just like you know
because I thought it was cool like on
the first American tour where it was
just like oh cool we're in like a
different state you know I just [__]
fast travel to another city yeah when
this one it was like I just fast
traveled to another country yeah and
that was like wild to me yeah and uh you
didn't need to show your passport as
well no that was that's nice uh I did
have no I know I know this but yeah this
is going to stand out for the rest of my
life
I remember so this wasn't on the tour
she uh uh this was like my first time in
Europe for a while uh so this was when I
was I went to Cologne for Gamescom yeah
uh so I land there
and there is two cues to get in the
borders one is the EU line and one is
the rest of the world line yeah right
and I'm like last time I came here it
was like post-brexit yeah but they still
allowed us to go to the EU line all
right so I go I go to like the nearest
clerk I'm like I have uh this passport
can I go in the EU line she looks at it
looks at me and just goes
[Music]
we flew from uh Germany to London and um
I I knew there was just going the all
other passports like in Europe yeah
um but obviously I mean you look at me
and a lot of people are like no no you
can you get on the EU on yeah this
happened in America they think no no go
to the citizens line no no no I'm I'm
not I'm not no I wish you get the fast
pass a lot a lot of the times yeah so we
were walking and they were like oh no
the EU passports that way and I show him
our British passport and grants with me
and he goes
you literally said uh
as she looked at the British passport
and I was like what
[Music]
2013 era British people were on top dude
yeah we had it passport game was strong
we were revered now man 10 years later
we are we are bottom of the battle yeah
we're now being British is a downside
[__] a passport's dog [__] it's funny
because like I have I have the opposite
uh every time I re-enter Japan you know
because I look like this
there's the Japan line and then there's
the rest of the world line yeah and I
always just you know without thinking I
just like start walking up to the
Japanese line always the dude like in
the middle is just like oh excuse me
and I just [__] pulled that [__] out
do you see this every time the guy's
like I'm so sorry even when you're a
foreign
form every single time you leave I don't
know if you have to do this in other
countries I've never had a Visa in
another country
um I don't think you do but in Japan
when you leave Japan you have to fill
out a form at the airport saying you're
going to come back to Japan right right
yeah which is so annoying doing this
every single time yeah but even then uh
when I go in that line they'll be like
oh no no tourists this way and I was
like this is literally for foreign
do you see my card yeah
so that's always a lot of fun a little
just micro complaints feel like it's
just kind of fun to have like to feel
special for a moment yeah yeah I'm
different
to Japan so many times yeah I can I
think I can like do a five minute
accuracy tell you when I'm gonna get out
of the airport because I've done it so
many times if I go now it's a gold split
by the Yeah by the time the plane lands
it's 15 minutes time out of the airport
yeah this is super fast yeah if you get
your bags in some checked bags yeah even
then you get your bags so fast in Japan
it's crazy totally it is and you do like
the uh Customs thing online
QR code and then little life hacks you
literally leave the terminal and the
taxi rank is like two seconds away you
go right down the stairs boom get in the
taxi I'm home like 40 minutes I'm like
all right I'm chilling Speed Run it's so
good I love I love airport
is such a good Airport please don't ever
fly into narrative if you can yeah yeah
it's gotten to the point now because
we've uh flown a lot this year for
business that like I've I've noticed
like little things about airports that
I've never noticed before like whenever
we go through security and it's like the
Giga chat [__] security machine you
know the big ones where you do not have
to remove your electronics or any like
liquids I'm like oh this is gonna be a
good experience and then you go to like
the beta little like [__] micro
machines where I I bring like everything
with me you know you know it depends how
beige and gray it looks Yeah the more
Beijing gray it looks the the more [__]
the security is going to be yes if it
looks really bright and modern it's just
easy yeah like the ones that hunted are
like the huge white machines like a
space portal they're so [__] yeah
yeah those those are the good ones oh do
I have to take my laptop out and it's
like no you don't it's like oh thank God
which one of you were they was that guy
giving a hard time at one of the
airports one of you you're getting like
grilled by the guy yeah that was me I'm
Nabi
um
Dublin there's Dublin right yeah Dublin
and then they made you take off your
shoes right yeah they made me take them
it was so weird I was like the I was
like sandwiched in between them and I'm
like we are literally all the same uh
yeah and I'm just chilling I mean I
thought I had a bad because I had to
take my shoes off this guy asked only
Joey to take his shoes off
and then I was like all right that's a
bit weird but whatever did it went
through finals like okay whatever I look
back God is emptying out his guns
getting the full course like the full
probe yeah this has never happened to me
before but I I took my liquids and uh my
laptops every election I've done this
enough times uh and for some reason uh
they're all like oh we need to re-put
your like repo your bag in so I just
thought oh maybe they need to re-put
their bag in uh and they asked me to
like empty everything I was like what is
the liquids yeah yeah pour them on the
table they literally like laid it out
like it was a CSI crime Scene you know
and they they took out did they do that
for you as well Navi yeah did they lay
it out like a crime scene I just had on
the tray I just like put it all back in
yeah like exhibiting I was just like
what is good and I felt so bad because I
saw you two just waiting for me and I'm
like ah guys I know what's going on this
has never happened before uh I'm just
I'm just trying to get through it was
funny yeah yeah sometimes yeah we give a
little bit of privilege
oh yeah I don't know it could have been
anything I don't know but I mean I I
never get stopped I I've never been
strange I've never been stopped at an
airport
I mean look at me I look so basic uh I
also like don't even I'm so bad now I've
gotten to the point where they always
scan my bag anyway because I bring so
many batteries and weird stuff in yeah I
don't even take the laptops out anymore
sometimes I just leave it all in because
they're gonna scan it anyway okay yeah
so I'm like I'll just leave it all in
and then like why'd you take it out I'm
like I forgot and then they forget about
it it's like it's like two I save time
because I don't want dude it's so
annoying I'm gonna [__] around with four
trays and then everyone's fighting to
get in and I'm like I'm just gonna put
it all in one yeah and then I'm gonna
deal with the guy and it's always like
the laptop always needs to be in a
separate tray from the bag and do you
ever get those times where because I
take um a laptop and like a switch oh
they don't want them on top of each
other and the tray is almost it's big
enough for one of them but it's just
about too small just to have them both
together the laptop is like here and
then the switch is like kind of leaning
on them yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
guy's just like no no no no you can't do
that you put it in a different tray and
I'm like oh yeah
yeah I do be like that but uh yeah
honestly literally first world problems
this is yeah I mean wait listen when you
spend like how many days a year we spent
in the airport you you notice you're
like damn this little agencies pissed me
off I genuinely Wonder this year since
we've been doing so much traveling like
if we were to calculated how many days
do you reckon we've been out of there I
was thinking about this the other day I
was thinking about how much time it's
been flying yeah I think we could easily
calculate it yeah I think I've spent
like at least 10 days in the air this
year at least yeah well the thing I've
seen that the thing that I've kind of
like taken like my mentality has changed
right now is you know there can be some
places like even flying to Europe where
in your mind it's like oh it's just an
hour and a half flight what you don't
really factor in for is the travel time
to the airport how long you have to stay
in the airport how long you have to like
the kind of like the hustle and bustle
things all that [__] getting through
customs and everything like that an hour
and a half flight to a different country
turns into like a four hour Journey out
of your day four to five hours yeah
sorry bullet trains are good yeah yeah
yeah right which is broke up five
minutes before okay yeah chilling get
some coffee and then you're off in like
two hours yeah yeah so good it's just
like travel days are more than just the
time on the vehicle it's like everything
around the [__] hell today as well
which you don't really factor into but
if you do it enough times you're like oh
this is a lot of hours in my life that
I'm losing like traveling I do think
when you travel uh a lot you get this
really weird perspective of travel uh
where I used to think of it as such a
huge event that I was like traveling and
then now I'm like oh no I just I just
don't think about it okay I'll do like a
four hour travel day and I'll be like oh
that's okay yeah I still have I still
have lunch and dinner yeah that's kind
of like the only thing that throws me
off if I can't have like a lunch or
dinner yeah I'm like ah I can't really
like pinpoint where where I'm at in the
day like does it do does the travel time
feel shorter for you yeah like because
like I've done shoots where I've taken
the bullet train to Kyoto yeah and then
come back in the evening and I'm like
that's weird because that's like a
that's like a five hour total Journey
but it doesn't feel that bad when you
kind of it's like spread out and then
you're also so used to traveling and
also you have a you get really good at
finding what to do while traveling I
think that's something yeah like I used
to always download like 500 Netflix
shows and I used to like prepare
everything I was gonna watch or what I
was going to read and then so what do
you go to now now I just I just I
figured out 10 minutes before I get on
the plane I'm like okay I'll download
this one Netflix thing and I'll probably
sleep and then I'll yeah yeah yeah I'll
buy the Wi-Fi and play some chess or
like I don't think about it too much I
know you do I know I constantly have a
library of things that I can watch I I
love I love traveling because it's my
one catch up on stuff yeah yeah it's my
one time when I can just shut off the
world I never buy the online Wi-Fi on my
Wi-Fi
I I maybe play a game with my switch or
I watch a movie or watch uh some anime
that I need to catch up on it's great
it's just a time where I can shut up
from the world and just do [__] that I
don't have to feel guilty you know doing
I guess and no one can fault you for it
because you're on a plane yeah yeah
exactly exactly I know I just I just say
oh yeah I'm sorry guys I'm not gonna
reply I want to play yeah but I have
internet I'm just readings well
sometimes you like it's just like you
don't have the vibe you know also you
know what pissed me off as well that I
found out uh I was like okay the first
time we ever took a like I ever took a
business class flight was like last year
I was super stoked about it and I was
super pumped because I thought like you
see all these videos you're like it
looks so luxurious and I was like oh
hell yeah you pay so much money for it
it's like a ridiculous amount and I was
like oh man I can't wait sit down like
open the Wi-Fi I'm like excuse me how do
I how do I get on the Wi-Fi trying to
make me pay she's like I don't know you
have to pay for the Wi-Fi I was like
what I just what this is like a five
thousand dollar plane seat I had to pay
twenty dollars for the Wi-Fi
[Music]
they still make you pay for Wi-Fi and I
found out it's because it's it's not run
by the plane it's like separately
contracted out it's some [__] weird
thing like that but I was like I was
like it's dumb dumbass [__] why
should I you already paid an ungodly
amount for like just a chair basically
that's slightly bigger what the [__] a
chair that's slightly bigger okay camera
climb yeah it can turn into a bed yeah
it's the game changer exactly that
doesn't mean let us make a 12 hour
flight a lot easier oh my God totally
yeah I mean would you guys
I don't know are you guys thinking about
traveling as much a lot next year
because we did a lot this year I mean I
say no but I will yeah that's kind of
what I figured out because like you know
last year I said the exact same thing
about 2023 I was like damn I did so much
travel in 2022. 2023 is going to be the
chill year turns out I've traveled more
this year than I think I have in my
entire life I think I only feel like
I've really traveled like a big amount
if it's longer than a week if it's less
than a week I don't think about it much
oh my God it's chill that's true yeah if
it's over than a week it's kind of a big
deal yeah I think I think that's what I
want to do more next year is just kind
of like non-work related short travel
you know maybe like uh less than a week
type of travel just because I want to go
somewhere you know like I still want to
explore like a ton of like Southeast
Asian countries because I just feel like
it's a waste to not go there living in
Asia you know yeah yeah so I want to do
more of that next year with Aki and like
yeah I don't know but again we say all
of this it's probably going to be more
traveling next year let's be real sure I
mean I mean traveling to America is a
must for work exactly I want to travel
more for Holiday yeah I want to I want
to take I want to take more holiday next
year totally yeah this has been uh great
that's why October November for me I'm
[__] staying in Japan I'm not I'm not
going anywhere I say that but I'm going
okay
so you're not so it's still Japan
technically yeah yeah yeah just just
three hours just a three-hour flight all
right completely changing gears since
this is a current episode Shore current
today it's been for a while so let's go
let's let's use the opportunity to talk
about something current so aside from
bread one question we got asked at every
show yep every show was our opinion of
the one piece live action yes which by
the time this has come out should have
come out about two weeks ago yeah three
weeks ago maybe two or three weeks ago
yeah
um well I I got one episode left to
watch oh yes I've watched seven episodes
okay because I've I've only seen the
first two and I'm saving the rest for
for other for my flight back I've
watched the door so okay yeah it's Eight
Episodes right it's Eight Episodes yeah
uh yeah it's fun
and that's that review
realization like I am watching it and
I'm having a good time but it it's like
I'm not like desperate to keep watching
you see what I mean like I don't feel do
you feel like that's because you already
are into one piece
I think there's definitely part of that
yeah I would love to be able to watch it
with a fresh perspective yeah because I
feel like it's way easier to go from
that to the manga rather than vice versa
yeah yes totally because like obviously
I have preconceived notions of segments
I really liked and when they changed
them I was like oh yeah why yeah it's
it's hard to get rid of that so like
yeah I think I think like honestly this
is honestly like one of the best
live-action adaptations I've ever seen I
think yeah as an adaptation it is 10 out
of 10 yeah as a standalone TV series
which I think is important to judge yeah
not just as an adaptation I think it's
like a fun seven or eight out of ten I'd
say I would give the entire one piece
live action like an 8 or 7.5 maybe yeah
like I don't feel like I could show it
to normies no actually I don't think I
think I think I think okay here's the
thing proper normies yeah yeah no no
okay this is this this showed me the one
piece live action showed me the power of
like why people are trying to make
live-action anime adaptations uh so like
I get like I get a message from my
cousin uh before the show and he's like
the biggest [__] Normie of all time
you know what I mean and it's not just
him uh his wife as well right yeah both
totally like uninterested in anime at
all and I get a message being like Oh I
know this is totally like not anime but
we watched the one piece live action
and we are we're actually like not just
me but my wife as well we're actually
really interested in getting into the
anime uh and uh and uh I was talking to
Sydney's brother as well who you know is
is more of a nerd but definitely not the
anime you know uh he watched the one
piece live action and he was like [__] I
did not think I would enjoy that but
that was really good maybe I just have
two maybe I'm two yeah you know we've
had to hide in the shadows for so long
anime fans yeah be very careful the
preconceived notion of like oh the live
action is for the anime fans only or
yeah yeah but I I think that's like so
like watching live action I think
there's two amazing things that they did
uh one was obviously I think like one of
the biggest weaknesses was you know
there are some moments especially I
think during our Long Park that don't
hit as hard as they did in the original
anime manga yeah yeah and you know I
think I think like in my personal
opinion along the Island Park Arc needed
and maybe an extra episode just to
really flesh out dude it's kind of did
you feel like other segments had too
many episodes yes yeah I felt like Usos
I felt like our Long Park could have
used that extra episode because that was
like one of the hardest hitting moments
I mean it wasn't like the moment was bad
it just definitely did not hit as hard
as it did in the anime or Manga just
because there was way less screen time
but you know you still had the important
moments and everything like that yeah
yeah uh so Sanji having a British accent
took something by surprise I'm not gonna
lie like a London accent I was like well
I did not expect that for someone
he's kind of like that what you mean my
cookies bad I really like that though I
I I like I really like God being
Scottish
I actually like the casting I actually
all I there's not a single casting I
didn't enjoy yeah I think all of them
were pretty spot-on I also like the fact
that they didn't resort to using like uh
you know high profile actors and
actresses yeah I also like there's a lot
of um a lot of the it looked kind of
goofy at times but a lot of them were
like just like practical effects for the
costumes yeah like they were like like
how long it looks [__] weird but he
would look weird so I'm kind of glad he
looks like weird the best the best way I
can say it which is one amazing thing
that they did is despite how [__]
Goofy and stupid all the character
designs are [__] they never fell like
anime you know they they felt like they
some of them fell anime I mean they
always felt like they existed in its own
fictional world right it didn't it
didn't feel like it didn't feel like I
was watching like a Japanese live-action
anime adaptation everyone try to act
like yeah like anime characters I just
felt like these just were goofy
characters in a goofy World it almost
felt like you know how have you got guys
ever seen like a stage play or something
like that yeah of course yeah so you
know how when you're watching a stage if
you have props that are meant to
represent something and you know you
it's not like a [__] Hollywood set
it's just a simple stage set or a prop
that is just give me to give you the
idea that's what it felt like you knew
that these practical effects and these
like makeup effects you knew that it
doesn't it doesn't exist in the real
world but they sold it enough that in
your mind you kind of like you allowed
your suspension of disbelief to really
go into this fictional world uh because
one of the thing I really think that the
one piece live action did correctly was
really sell you on the whole world of
One Piece you know this fictional the
World building of one piece with like
all of these different factions the
fishmen and everything as well I didn't
realize how I won't lie it it did piss
me off after a while or he kept saying
I'm going to become king of the Pirates
when you read it it isn't that annoying
but you said like every two minutes and
I was like okay I get it I get I get it
I get it I get it I get it but it's your
thing and you do this a lot but my God
stop it and also there's a few moments
uh like again like I think it was it was
a it did a lot of amazing things and it
was really fun there were a few moments
where the dialogue really did take me
out of it for a moment and I felt like
it could have been a little bit better
oh [__] I was watching episode six and
it felt like it's there was like I can't
remember there was one scene where they
like I think they were around the bed
and there was just this scene where it
felt like they were all just talking
separately and they weren't talking to
each other and it was really weird it
was very bizarre it was like a really
weird conversation because then there
were some other conversations that were
really good like every Garb scene like I
kind of I thought that it was kind of
interesting how they did this dialogue
um but and there's also here uh did you
see the when I watched it I thought it
was a weird transition and then I'm so
glad that someone posted it on Twitter
and thought this was a weird transition
because I felt so validated there's a
transition when they did with like a
with the go board oh I remember and it
was so [__] weird they did a
transition way they put a piece on the
go board and then the go piece
transitioned into Luffy's hat top down
it was a very janky transition and then
they also
walked on their Mark kind of weird like
Luffy didn't start walking until someone
walked next to him so he has a flight to
say his Market it's kind of weird they'd
I it was just it was a very nitpick but
it's just kind of things that like kind
of you can't get like for a moment
you're like oh yeah okay this is a show
yeah and you know those are very very
very slight nitpicks but I think yeah I
think I think it's you should when you
watch a show like this and everyone's
getting so hyped around it I think it is
fair to be like hey there it's okay to
have some things you didn't like yeah
and have some concerns because I I do
feel like there there were so many micro
decisions that I noticed that and maybe
not a lot of people noticed that I think
really worked well yeah there's some
very good quality of life changes yeah
like I felt it was [__] genius to
have only certain characters shout out
attack names right right because I think
there is only Luffy buggy and at the end
Sanji who shouts out attack names right
and it all felt in character like like
you know you know like because I was
wondering I was wondering when I was
watching the trailer if people shout out
attack names it's gonna be cheesy as
[__] but you know when Luffy shouts up
when buggy shouts out I'm like all right
you know that's it's because it's
because it's Luffy and that's their
character yeah yeah but any everyone
else is just like it's such a normal
fight scene and I thought that was
[__] genius because I I don't know if
I could you know like maybe take Zorro
seriously
yeah my I guess my now that I'm really
done with it and I'm like I would like
to watch more yeah my concern is how do
you make more how because how do you
make Chopper okay that's the biggest
version of characters a lot of fights
that get really weird really bizarre and
I feel like the start of one piece is
when it's most adaptable in terms of
one-to-one live action because it's like
simplicity is it still it does is the
gum you know the gum gum [__] is weird
but I mean that's they clear they did a
great job animating that stuff yeah but
how when it gets really [__] weird
also it's long we these characters are
gonna get old yeah the attack is gonna
get old yeah the budget is crazy like
how do you how do you go about this I
would like to see more that's why I know
that's why I actually really hope that I
want more yeah I definitely want more
because I feel like they would give a
little more time now now that I know
that it is for Success it is popular uh
especially when it gets Alabaster that
that gets like more than two episodes
like 17 million dollars on average an
episode was it sheesh let's do where'd
you get that from I don't know I saw it
can we fact yes how much what was the
budget well I guess I guess the ones uh
I guess to answer your question while
we're checking uh one thing that I was
actually like very impressed with uh in
terms of like the writing which was like
I was so scared of going into the one
piece live action is uh I call it
[__] Marvel syndrome
that's a lot of money
um the level of success that it needs to
sustain that is good I think it's got it
I think it's it's it's it's proven that
it's value in it yeah the set design was
insane yeah I mean I just hope that they
can keep the budget going and the show
keeps popping off because I again I want
to see more of it yeah because like I
was like as I was saying I think the
reason why the goofiness kind of worked
was like it didn't do this thing which I
think a lot of Hollywood films and
especially Marvel movies do where you
know when like something weird happens
especially like there's a there's a
thing in like Ant-Man uh the new Ant-Man
where one of the characters looks
[__] like atrocious like an
Abomination and the entire joke is just
everyone laughing at how stupid this guy
looks look at this big guy with this
like wide face haha it's so funny uh and
considering how many weird things happen
in one piece there was never a single
moment where the joke was wow this is
that just happened that was weird I just
saw a cloud yeah they never they never
pointed out yeah they never pointed it
out and that yeah that like that that it
looks funny look at that look at that
and actually they trusted the joke yeah
they had faith in it yeah and like they
like subconsciously because none of the
characters felt it was weird yeah I
didn't think it was weird because no one
pointed out how weird it was so I was
like oh this is just normal to exist in
this world yeah so even if something's
looked out of place none of the
characters really Drew attention to it
so I didn't draw attention to it and I
thought that was [__] genius in terms
of the right time yeah I hope we get
more I hope it doesn't take forever
obviously there's a lot of strikes going
on right now so we're pretty much you
know I'm not gonna be for a while which
sucks because I I wonder if they're
gonna have to do like a James Cameron
approach where you film as much of it
now while the actors are all still young
yeah because oh my God this is this is
gonna be if they do it if they film it
as they're like I guess reaching it
it'll be like what like 15 years well
how long did the one-piece live action
take for production again it was like I
don't know two two years two three years
ago I think it was longer than that yeah
it's like four or five years
apparently the script's ready the next
one oh yeah but they just need to the
the strikes need to be agreed and stuff
which obviously uh means that it yeah
it's uh we're not going to see it for a
while yeah which kind of sad because I I
the one thing that kind of sucks about
current TV is that because they have to
wait to see how a show does we often
have massive gaps between season one and
two of shows because you know back in
the day they'd be like oh yeah this is a
good pilot give it 900 episodes yeah uh
you know so you get a lot and it was it
was good uh yeah like 2024 early 2025
that means early 2025 for sure there's
no way that definitely means early 2020.
earliest uh there's no way yeah so we're
gonna have to wait like two years so I
don't know if this is a hot take it
might be a hot take okay
I think I know you're gonna say that the
one-piece live action is a better
introduction than the anime okay wait do
you okay does this include the manga
it does
I think a lot of people agree that the
anime is extremely slow until it starts
and the pacing is the main issue and the
reason why a lot of people get turned
off and I think this is a I mean the
fact that we get through 10 volumes in
what doesn't feel like too long okay I
think that's fair uh so yes if I knew
the person was an anime fan or like
already into like anime and manga I
would recommend the manga yeah but if
you're someone who maybe has no interest
in anime or Manga I would actually
recommend the live action over any other
one piece media to get them into the
world of One Piece how many episodes
does it take for them to finish our Long
Park in the anime
52s yeah yeah it's a lot that's just too
much yeah yeah that's that's J that's
just too much yeah I mean that's what if
if you cut down the one piece I've
actually read what 20 episodes yeah
because it's like about an hour I think
I think you know I think our Long Park
is definitely stronger in the anime for
sure for like the trade-off you get for
like the impact of our Long Park uh and
maybe some of like sanji's are kidding
less strongly with the anime I think
that's offset by just how streamlines
the live action is it feels way more
streamlined you know there's there's a
lot of fats that has been trimmed off
um and just the way that characters get
introduced I feel like because you know
in like the anime or the manga it's like
every character one episode at a time
gets introduced and you're like okay
it's a very sluggish start whereas in
the live action we get like Nami and
Zoro uh just introduce her once and you
get that or you get that all one thing I
really like you almost get that instant
chemistry which between the like the
banter between three of them almost like
after episode one and that's that's what
I love about one yeah I think it makes
sense though because like especially
with the manga for instance like you
know it was the the story was just
starting off so I think Odo was still
trying to get a footing on like okay
what's the like the general Vibe I want
to go with when introducing these
characters or like you know what's like
the most best way to do it so I think he
was like kind of testing out a lot of
things in terms of like how to
streamline that story whereas now that
it's been so established and you know he
was part of the writing team for the
live action he was just like all right I
know exactly what I did right what I did
wrong when I first started the manga so
we're just gonna cut off all the you
know [__] parts that I included in the
manga and just like make it so that it
was straight up I was the very skeptical
I was like I don't know how well he'll
know how to translate it to film or be
able to assist with that obviously I
think the writing team crushed it yeah
and obviously having his supervision
probably definitely helped it's cool I'm
just glad it worked out I'm happy I'm
happy you got something that's great and
uh I choose to hope that now it doesn't
struggle to
get off and get into uh I really hope it
doesn't start a trend of now I mean it's
already started the trend live action
everyone wants to do live action anime I
mean look at all like your Academia live
action is in the works right now look at
the look at the budget and the amount of
time and the amount of care that's to go
into make yeah just a good live action
annotation like this is just this is on
on ungodly amounts of resources yeah
the probably the problem is Avatar
cannot make death note work it's a live
action you you are beyond all hope of
saving it is such a an easy formula yeah
for a good thriller like it's such a
straightforward premise that the only
hard thing to kind of really fit in is
the Shinigami yeah uh and if you can
nail that the story's laid out for you
like it's it I don't feel like it should
be that hard but yet they still [__]
they're still [__] it up yeah watch uh
I'm hoping bro if we can't get a [__]
I mean they [__] up the first one so
wait there's a Pokemon live action
coming out too I could see that working
I mean again
it's great yeah yeah that's true there's
one my hero Academia I'm scared about
I'm very scared of that one I am very
very scared about uh yeah and it's Zack
Snyder as well is it Disney oh it's
Disney oh no oh no no it's not it's
Netflix okay yeah well they nailed them
hear me out guys [__] off maybe they can
make it better
here's the deal here's the deal uh
Netflix now gets one good and Anime
adaptation Faith they get one we all
gonna be like guys hear the map yeah and
if they [__] it up we're all gonna go
back to being like one piece was a fluke
it was a it was a one-off this doesn't
happen because the problem with one
piece is that on paper it shouldn't have
worked like no no out of every live I
think every single one piece fan thought
it was gonna be dog oh yeah holy [__]
yeah
um and it was just one piece maybe maybe
I'm being that toxic one-piece fan right
now but maybe it's just maybe it's just
because out maybe it's just because one
piece is goated you know maybe that was
the reason okay all right
all right all right well that's our
thoughts on one piece everyone has been
asking us there it is that's it and
that's how the European tour went yeah
so thank you to uh everyone who came out
to see us yeah which is absolutely
awesome and uh Germans I am sorry
it'll take another two years but maybe
I'll have another Redemption off it's uh
Tantra redeem himself well I'm in the
same boat as you're gone and I've been
to Germany a lot so hate me now I got I
got your backs Jones don't worry about
that but uh Joey do the thing hey look
at all these patrons though did you see
them on the screen right now oh my God
hey if you like to support us then go
over to our patreon patreon.com trash
days also follow us on Twitter send us
your memes on the subreddit and if you
hate our face listen to us on Spotify
and uh we're gonna do a few more
episodes in the studio so yeah yeah all
right see you guys bye
[Music]
foreign